ah
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález de manera
pacífica 5.3 millones de hondureños
fueron a las urnas en unas elecciones
generales que no sólo permiten elegir al
nuevo presidente de la nación sino
también legisladores y algunas
autoridades municipales de esta manera
se pondrá fin a ocho años de gobierno de
juan orlando hernández un mandatario
controvertido señalado por eeuu de estar
relacionado con narcotráfico dichas
elecciones estuvieron también marcadas
por la polarización ciudadana por
algunos rezagos del golpe militar del
2009 también algunos fallos tecnológicos
y un temor al fraude electoral entre los
ciudadanos sin embargo la participación
ciudadana fue alta pero varios
hondureños en eeuu un país en donde
viven más de un millón de ellos se
quejaron por no haber podido recibir la
nueva tarjeta de identidad o de
identificación por lo que no pudieron
ejercer su derecho al voto y son
votantes cruciales en estas elecciones
en honduras xiomara castró es la
candidata de la coalición de
centroizquierda
asfura es el candidato del oficialismo
del partido nacional que lideraron la
intención de voto así fue cómo
transcurrió la jornada veamos
xiomara castró la opción de izquierda
del partido libertad y refundación ya se
ha declarado ganadora de las elecciones
entre los vítores de sus seguidores
buenas noches
[Aplausos]
porque voy
el pueblo se ha manifestado
y ha hecho valer esa frase
solo el pueblo
la esposa del expresidente depuesto por
un golpe de estado en 2009 manuel zelaya
ha basado su campaña en la lucha contra
la corrupción y el narcotráfico
devolviendo el peso a la izquierda en el
país tras 12 años no obstante el partido
nacional con el continuista nasry asfura
como candidato también se autoproclamó
vencedor a pesar de su clara desventaja
vamos ganando nuestros movilizadores nos
informan que llegamos
1.225.000 nacionalistas registrados que
han votado por papi a la orden
cachurecos cuidemos y defendamos
nuestros votos estas elecciones han
estado marcadas por la alta
participación por encima del 68% un
récord para la nación centroamericana
algo que los expertos explican con el
rechazo al presidente juan orlando
hernández que termina su segundo mandato
en medio de acusaciones por corrupción y
conexiones con el narcotráfico y también
por el hartazgo de la población debido a
la crisis económica y el alto índice de
pobreza problemas que tendrá que
enfrentar la persona que finalmente
ocupe la presidencia del país
bueno seguimos a la espera de uno son
resultados definitivos todo puede
suceder en este momento en honduras los
dos candidatos líderes en la votación se
proclamaron triunfadores ya lo veían
ustedes en el informe pero el conteo de
los votos sigue en marcha qué es lo que
necesita honduras en este momento cuáles
son las necesidades políticas más
urgentes como devolverle a los
ciudadanos la confianza en las
instituciones en este proceso electoral
también para despejar ese fantasma del
fraude hoy en el debate de france 24
analizamos el panorama político de
honduras de cara a estas elecciones
generales en ese país centroamericano y
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
josé filadelfo martínez él es analista
político está en la ciudad de
tegucigalpa la capital hondureña también
allí en tegucigalpa está con nosotros
edgardo rodríguez también analista
político y en el estudio de france 24
nos acompaña miguel gómez ls profesor de
la facultad de ciencias políticas y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad de la pontificia universidad
javeriana en la ciudad de bogotá la
capital colombiana ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y
todas sus preguntas lo pueden hacer a
través de nuestras redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram y
también en twitter estamos como france24
guión bajo s arroba santi luego que es
mi cuenta personal nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo
entonces con
filadelfo en la ciudad de tegucigalpa en
jose bienvenido al programa gracias por
acompañarnos hoy y quiero conocer cuál
es su balance de esta jornada electoral
en donde hubo una relativa alta
participación de hondureños como lo ve
usted
el balance para mí es altamente positivo
contento porque las elecciones han sido
pacíficas hasta ahora los resultados son
creíbles
para mí el
primero de 12 años de gobierno pero
también del clientelismo del gobierno
del partido nacional apeló al
clientelismo para operar la voluntad de
los votantes pero finalmente los
voluntad de los votantes se rebelaron y
votaron por una opción que ofrece la
oportunidad de cambiar el rumbo del país
se abre una ventana para que honduras
pueda corregir difíciles problemas que
tenemos y ojalá el partido de la
fundación pueda hacerlo
es una muestra de que cuando la
democracia
tiene actores muy importantes puede
funcionar y puede contribuir a resolver
los problemas estructurales que hay en
la economía y en la sociedad en
definitiva yo estoy muy satisfecho y
preocupado por los grandes retos que
puede cambiar su rumbo
jose entonces satisfechos hoy en
tegucigalpa y que dice edgardo rodríguez
también hay en la capital hondureña
bueno yo igual que mi amigo estoy
contento porque tuvimos una jornada
pacífica una jornada altamente
participativa y como
se han señalado los los datos de
participación
del 68% no lo habíamos tenido en un buen
tiempo atrás
y eso fortalece la democracia la
ciudadanía expresó de manera categórica
como nunca antes en la historia habíamos
tenido un ganador con una diferencia tan
amplia bueno - hasta el momento no
sabemos si al final del conteo pues
puede aumentar o disminuir esa esa
distancia creo que sólo en 2009 y
después del acontecimiento del 28 de
junio tuvimos una elección
presidencial con un amplio margen que
tuvo con un 15 por ciento
así que esa fue la elección más digamos
por la diferencia más alta que hemos
tenido sin embargo la de ayer se
encamina también para hacer una elección
histórica una derrota aplastante al
partido nacional que sin duda alguna va
a provocar
cambios
y autocríticas
y una serie de reposicionamientos que el
escenario político hondureño no
solamente para el partido nacional
también para el partido liberal que sale
aún más golpeado la elección 36 17
y aquí en el estudio de france 24 para
terminar con esta ronda miguel
bienvenido buenas noches su opinión
sobre estos comicios presidenciales pues
estoy de acuerdo en parte con lo que se
ha dicho pero no sería tampoco tan
optimista por varias varias razones
primera cosa creo que falta por ver los
resultados a las elecciones legislativas
que es algo crucial en la gobernabilidad
de los próximos años también diría que
la situación que enfrenta el país es
bastante
desafiante para los próximos años
entonces a pesar de que haya un cambio
en la presidencia sería bastante cauto
porque pues hay desafíos por ejemplo con
la deuda pública desafíos con las
migraciones elementos como el ascenso de
la pobreza debido también a las
tormentas tropicales y la pandemia que
hacen que pues si bien es alentador
efectivamente el clima de una jornada
electoral que ha sido positiva también
hay que un poco valenciano porque pues
venimos de algunos meses donde ha habido
violencia política tampoco hay que
olvidar que durante un año ha habido más
de 60 asesinados e líderes políticos
asesinados en el país por lo cual pues
si bien la jornada electoral en sí ha
sido muy esperanzadora creo que hay que
situarlo en contexto de grandes desafíos
grandes desafíos son los que tiene
honduras por delante a partir de esta
elección presidencial le pregunto a jose
en tegucigalpa
de acuerdo a los resultados que tenemos
en este momento
xiomara castró que es la candidata de
esta coalición de centroizquierda va
liderando el conteo de los votos todavía
no hay un resultado oficial esto
rompería o terminaría con 12 años de
gobierno del partido nacional dos
periodos consecutivos de juan orlando
hernández que es el cambio que ya
representa que ha sido avalado con estos
votos de los hondureños y si es un voto
auténtico o es un voto simplemente de
castigo hacia el partido nacional como
lo vio usted
es una suma este es un voto de castigo
pero también es un voto auténtico de un
sector importante de la población que
quiere cambios y los retos sin dudas son
son enormes y es difícil pero creo que
el gran desafío que tiene el partido que
está ganando ahora las elecciones que
llamar al diálogo se recupera la
confianza en el gobierno una dificultad
que tenemos con el gobierno que va a
seguir es que no tenía la capacidad de
convocar generaba mucha desconfianza y
ahora tenemos una distrital presidenta
que puede convocarse diálogo y puede
unir diferentes fuerzas para enfrentar
los problemas que ya se ha mencionado
como el narcotráfico de dilucidar hasta
donde es cierto lo de la violencia
política es importante porque los
últimos datos dicen que también en el
botón legislativo el cual quiero
libertad y refundación tiene como tiene
una victoria aplastante entonces vamos a
ver una correlación de fuerza distinta y
del congreso tirar la oportunidad de que
se modifique y esas leyes
y ha servido para legitimar para
facilitar la corrupción entonces es una
ventana muy importante que creo que hay
que valorarlas positivamente
en la capital hondureña se borraría de
esta forma con esta virtual con este
virtual triunfo de xiomara castró esos
fantasmas del 2009 de ese rumbo hacia la
izquierda que iba a tomar honduras con
el presidente zelaya que es el esposo de
la candidata castro
esa es la gran interrogante que nos
hacemos muchos iba a adoptar el partido
libre por
sucumbir a las fuerzas más hacia la
izquierda de ese partido en sus vínculos
con cuba venezuela nicaragua y el foro
de sao paulo esa es la gran interrogante
y ellos van a continuar en esa línea de
la izquierda un poco más radical o por
el contrario que entendieron que la
posición política ideológica de la
mayoría de los hondureños no están hacia
la izquierda esa es una pregunta que
todos nos estamos haciendo va a ser el
tiempo el que no se conteste esa
pregunta que
matiza o sea a dónde se va a orientar
este gobierno tentativamente yo diría
que ellos tendrán que ser muy tantos
en los primeros años de su gobierno
porque en los distintos sectores van a
estar muy expectantes ante cualquier
giro bruce que pueda llegar y digamos
los sectores más de en el partido
libre y aquí en el estudio france24
miguel le pregunto esos fantasmas
todavía rondan allí en la política
hondureña esos hechos del 2009 cuando
hubo este golpe que derrocó al
presidente zelaya un presidente que
estaba llevando el país hacia una
tendencia izquierda que era muy popular
en ese momento en américa latina tenía
mucha fuerza por lo menos a nivel
político hoy en día el panorama político
le permitiría a honduras tomar ese rumbo
de acuerdo cómo está el panorama en la
región y en el país yo creo que hay que
ser cautos en el análisis en varios
niveles primero el contexto
internacional es muy distinto a lo que
representa a honduras hoy día para eeuu
no es lo mismo que hace 10 años ahí es
clave el desafío que representa a
honduras para bailén hoy día no porque y
eso es muy interesante se llamará ya
dijo que estaba dispuesta a reconocer
china continental
con una política exterior tradicional de
honduras de reconoce a taiwán es un
elemento central que ya muestra hacia
dónde van a ir los tiros pero también
diría que el partido libre ha mostrado
esa capacidad de ser más pragmático en
este contexto soy un poco más digamos
esperanzado estoy más esperanzado de que
la política por ejemplo pública que
proponga el partido sea mucho más
contenida porque había un aprendizaje en
los últimos 10 años el partido ya forma
parte del espectro político se ha
insertado en el sistema por el sistema
político por lo cual diría que no es
para nada la misma situación e inclusive
hay elementos que pueden jugar a favor
no herramientas de negociación que puede
jugar a favor del gobierno como por
ejemplo el tema de las migraciones como
por ejemplo el tema
también de la posición de honduras hoy
día para eeuu en centroamérica porque
evidentemente eeuu también está mirando
a honduras con mucho cuidado igual que
china entonces aquí el valor de lo que
son las elecciones hondureñas y lo que
representa el gobierno y las
perspectivas políticas son distintas
hace unos años no tiene nada que ver
continúo con usted miguel para hacerle
una pregunta a nivel de lo que significa
este partido político esta alternancia
que podría tener lugar en en honduras
esto es un síntoma de mejora en la
democracia esta alternancia de poder en
el país y también rompe digamos este
bipartidismo al que fue sometido
honduras a lo largo de tantos años y le
daría un respiro político con cuál es su
impresión al respecto bueno en américa
latina' y 22 países que tuvieron la
particularidad de tener un sistema de
partidos políticos que no fue modificado
en la transición a la democracia
paraguay honduras lo interesante del
caso hondureño es justamente que el
libre pasa reemplazada hasta cierto
punto el partido liberal que ha ido
cayendo en el apoyo popular pero también
aquí algo muy interesante libre se ha
ido haciendo cada vez más del statu quo
y aquí hay que ser también muy claros
libre en realidad no es una ruptura tan
fuerte como se pretende desde fuera hay
que ser muy cauto sobre cómo valoramos
justamente esa futura presidencia de
xiomara hay que hay que ver claramente
unos nexos con por ejemplo los círculos
empresariales y es interesante que
inclusive los empresarios ya han
respaldado entonces demuestra que hay
una normalización de esas perspectivas
pero también una ambición por buscar
ciertas soluciones que porque vayan por
fuera de lo de la visión más
conservadora que ha habido en los
últimos 12 años claro le pregunto ahora
a edgardo hago la ronda a la inversa
para cambiar la dinámica le pregunto por
los entes electorales en estos comicios
presidenciales y también legislativos
estaban bajo la lupa de todos los
observadores y de la comunidad
internacional estaba en juego la
credibilidad de la institucionalidad
hondureña por lo que ha sucedido a lo
largo de estos años bajo el gobierno de
juan orlando hernández hubo
transparencia hubo independencia por
parte de los organismos y también llama
mucho la atención desde afuera de las
fronteras hondureñas que la autoridad
pueda tomarse hasta casi 30 días para
poder dar un resultado definitivo de las
de las elecciones no es mucho tiempo
cuál es su opinión
no diremos el caso de bolivia
donde estuvo casi un mes
la ley electoral
[Música]
electoral
fui muy crítico durante esta nueva
institucionalidad es realmente reciente
sin embargo y
tuvo muchos muchas del todo este año una
confrontación entre los tres miembros
los concejales que dirigen este ente
electoral hubo pleitos constantes
durante todo el año y eso que generó una
gran preocupación como un retraso en
todos los procesos de compras
contrataciones de los sistemas y los
equipos necesarios para los comicios del
día de ayer sin embargo
al final de la formada al filo de la
jornada el consejo nacional electoral
cumplió cumplió la tecnología que vio la
rapidez de la entrega de la información
esto no lo cubrimos en el 2017 y también
fallas similares del 2013
debilidades a las confrontaciones
finalmente el consejo nacional electoral
salió bien librado creo que con bastante
transparencia la tecnología funcionó y
ayudó muchísimo a aliado tanto es que
hasta este minuto no hay mayor
controversia sobre los resultados en los
tres niveles electivos pensé que la
página en internet del consejo electoral
estuvo de baja durante prácticamente
toda la jornada jose su opinión sobre el
desempeño de la entidad de la
institución electoral hondureña
transparencia hay confianza en los
resultados confianza en esta
institucionalidad los hondureños ya han
expresado varias veces su desconfianza
en diferentes órganos del estado
si usted no está el mismo pregunta una
semana antes yo iré estresado cualquier
cantidad de dudas no deja de ser una
sorpresa
como finalmente el consejo estuvo
digamos a la altura de las
circunstancias primera por voluntad
propia creo que diversos sectores de la
sociedad donde venía presionaron incluso
a la comunidad internacional la visita
de un funcionario del gobierno de eeuu
es clave para demandar esto es decir ese
es el resultado de muchas cuestiones y
no y a pesar de que yo manifiesto
el agrado no hay que descartar que van a
derrumbar incidencias que va a haber
dificultades pero creo que van a ser
mínimas el hecho de que el país ahora
esté en total calma es un reflejo de
esto y hace falta mucho por hacer para
construir una institucionalidad
electoral que responda a los conceptos
de la democracia es uno de los grandes
retos que tiene el próximo gobierno el
próximo congreso de la república
devolver la confianza la seguridad de
las instituciones públicas y yo aquí sí
coincido en el sentido de que
xiomara castró no de la esposa del
presidente zelaya durante el periodo
2005-2009 es una mujer que se ha
transformado mucho ha aprendido creo y
que va a tomar en consideración va a ser
pragmática en el sentido de que libre
ofrece muchas cosas pero finalmente lo
importante es mantener la estabilidad
natural y salir a flote porque el
problema del narcotráfico no se va a
resolver de la noche a la mañana el
problema de las caravanas el problema de
la pobreza y todos estos problemas
requieren unidad no sólo de gobierno
sino de otra política
lo que se viene ahora y ojalá la
presidente electa tenga la capacidad
para asumir ese liderazgo que el país
demanda virtualmente electa todavía no
hay resultados definitivos o se le
preguntó por los candidatos por estas
dos personas que están disputando la
presidencia por nasry asfura y xiomara
castro comenzó preguntándole por pura
que es el alcalde de la capital alcalde
de tegucigalpa muy carismático conocida
en la escena política hondureña vendió
su campaña con
apodo se le conoce como papilla y en
honduras un eventual gobierno de asfura
como presidente honduras como lo vería
usted que tendencia tendría que enfoque
tendría
que sería un gobierno
que no genere entusiasmo que tenemos
ahora un gobierno que tendría que
manejar las mismas dificultades que el
gobierno actual con el sobrecargo de que
se tiene que abordar el tema de que se
va a hacer con el presidente
hernández que eventualmente puede ser
acusado por eeuu y que si él es
presidente tendrá que aplicar la ley de
extradición es decir sería una situación
muy compleja que se le viene encima y
creo que finalmente en ese sentido del
partido nacional no deja de ser ganador
porque va de asumir esos grandes retos
que están ahora por delante de verdad el
país está en una situación muy
complicada y en el que el candidato
asegura le mostró gran carisma pero creo
que no logró algo fundamental ni
siquiera municipios de partido lo que
nos están diciendo los primeros datos es
que una buena parte del electorado del
partido nacional no se movilizó votar
por su partido y esto es una señal de
que ofrece a su popularidad no tuvo esa
capacidad
es muy diciente y le pregunto a edgardo
cómo vería usted un eventual gobierno de
xiomara castró en honduras qué rumbo
podría tener el país desde esta
desde esta líder hacia del estado
bueno como ella misma lo ha dicho que va
a intentar
reconciliar al país y el partido libre y
su esposo dirigen que fue una fuerza
altamente confrontativa durante los
últimos 12 años
ellos implementaron lo que se llamó la
insurrección
legislativa organizaron los comandos y
regionales el año 2017
ellos fueron parte de esa confrontación
pero ahora ellos son gobierno ahora
cambia el papel que ellos necesitan en
gobernabilidad para hacer un gobierno
estable así yo creo que ella va a
esforzarse por propiciar ese diálogo que
ellos pues digamos matizaron la
confrontación en su momento y
el país lo necesita los distintos
sectores pero que van a estar abiertos a
ese diálogo a ese entendimiento dice que
va a ser un gobierno de integración
lo cual también va en la línea o la
reconciliación y bajar ese nivel de
confort en un país que en los últimos 11
años
el nivel de polarización y de
computación han llegado al límite
realmente preocupantes claro un gobierno
de integración miguel xiomara castró
tendrá la capacidad de unificar y
mantener esta coalición tal vez convocar
otros espectros políticos del paisaje
político hondureño y romper un poco esa
polarización dentro de la sociedad no es
una buena pregunta pero yo creo que ahí
hay claves de análisis que sería primero
el país es profundamente joven es decir
el país ha cambiado mucho en nuestros
últimos 15 años muchos de los votantes
hoy día tienen menos de 30 años y
honduras en un país muy joven por lo
cual eso es una clave en la disposi y
disponibilidad por cambiar las cosas
segundo también yo creo que hay un
hartazgo brutal en relacionados a los
casos de corrupción hay una demanda
frente a una depuración un poco del
estado y también por ejemplo las
experiencias positivas de la mcs y que
funciona hasta llegamos al año pasado
mostraron que había posibilidades de
mejorar de aprender por ejemplo en el
ministerio público en la lista la lucha
contra la corrupción pero también yo
creo que aquí hay grandes desafíos donde
si puede haber acuerdo y otros no cuáles
puede haber acuerdo por ejemplo temas
más económicos yo creo que de xiomara es
mucho más pragmática en la visión en la
visión digamos de la política económica
por ejemplo yo creo que la posición ha
ido cambiando también en ciertos
aspectos por ejemplo los cds que no
tienen mucho apoyo por parte de
población y que le han ayudado a tener
un poco más de popularidad pero después
hay otros temas que sí van a polarizar y
forzosamente van a llegar a polarizar
pienso por ejemplo en el tema del aborto
que es un tema drástico y efectivamente
como lo dijeron cuando eras un país muy
conservador en algunos aspectos entonces
hay cierta digamos hay ciertas
propuestas que forzosamente van a llevar
a una polarización pues yo no diría eso
como algo negativo sino que hay ciertos
debates que si se tienen que dar no por
ejemplo pienso en los asesinatos
las personas trans en honduras que es un
tema gravísimo y son temas que hay que
dejar ver en la luz del día de la
discusión política y que tienen que ser
tratados entonces no forzosamente es
malo que no haya una capacidad de
reconciliación sino que tiene que haber
diálogo que es algo distinto pero si
termino con algo es xiomara siempre ha
sido muy enfática sobre ese mensaje de
reconciliación lo cual ha sido muy
positivo creo desde el principio no
siempre se ha mostrado como una persona
dialogante y es su positivo quiero
preguntarle ahora a edgardo sobre cómo
puede ser esta relación entre
tegucigalpa y washington con el gobierno
del presidente vayan teniendo sobre la
mesa el tema migratorio que es sumamente
complejo para los dos países
washington tiene la lupa puesta en lo
que está pasando en este momento en el
país hubo ya un distanciamiento durante
el gobierno trump como puede ser esa
relación entre los dos países ya pasó
darle la palabra también a jose
bueno las relaciones con eeuu es una
relación estable de eeuu acá en el
sentido que eeuu le interesa que haya
estabilidad política que haya seguridad
jurídica y seguridad de las personas en
honduras y combate a la corrupción en la
pobreza eso no ha variado la relación
con eeuu en la medida en que la señora
xiomara castro pueda tener un diálogo
frontal con eeuu en esos temas para ver
relativa de una buena relación
eeuu ha variado muchísimo su postura
respecto a américa latina y la mayor
parte del punto ellos ya no estaban como
hace 10 15 20 años atrás interviniendo
en la política interna de estos países
sino más bien una política de buenos
vecinos una política de contención en
los temas que a ellos les interesa
seguridad migración
eeuu es importante más de un millón de
hondureños viven en este país viven dos
unidos muchos de ellos se quejaron
porque no pudieron votar en estos
comicios
el domingo pasado precisamente por un
cambio en el documento de identidad
muchos no lo recibieron y no pudieron
ejercer su derecho al voto
jose de su opinión sobre cómo pueden ser
estas relaciones con washington y le
añado otro personaje en el escenario
china
yo creo que ambos tienen que superar la
desconfianza de eeuu
con relación a la crisis y el propio
golpe no simpatizo con el partido
libertad y refundación precisamente con
el presidente zelaya
una etapa en que eeuu tiene que tiene
que aceptar la decisión de polonia pero
también ocurre en el lado contrario pero
ya hay algunas señales con el
nombramiento de una nueva embajadora en
tegucigalpa el partido de la fundación
esas declaraciones
digamos amistosas así eeuu pero yo yo en
general con relación a centroamérica
creo que eeuu tiene que revisar su
política hasta ahora ha sido errática en
el tema de inmigración en el tema del
narcotráfico hay que decirlo nosotros
tenemos violencia porque el gobierno
corruptos pero en gran medida también
por el narcotráfico ya no existe porque
hay una demanda de dos en eeuu si eso se
pudiera superar
yo creo que mejoraría la situación en
centroamérica y eso es claro
y en el tema de china y otro que eeuu
tiene más problemas con el salvador con
relación a china creo que va a poderlo
manejar con honduras como se hizo aquí
reiteradamente el partido de la
fundación probablemente sea mucho más
pragmático y se dé cuenta que no ha
llegado la hora pese a que se ha
declarado
muchas cosas una nueva constituyente de
las cocinas y creo que
en aras de lograr la gobernabilidad que
se requiere para asegurar
a
la recta final del programa miguel
quiero hacerle esta pregunta lo de la
relación con washington y con china el
papel que pueda haber allí en la región
y el tema migratorio que es sumamente
importante para todo el continente yo
creo que ahí hay que hacer una precisión
primero sobre el tema las migraciones
todo el mundo sigue pensando que es un
tema de seguridad y estoy de acuerdo
evidentemente en el triángulo del norte
de problemas de seguridad pero también
un tema de cambio climático en el correo
seco hay gente que ya no puede cultivar
como lo hacía antes por lo cual hay
mucha gente que está huyendo por las
consecuencias mismas del cambio
climático honduras en unos países más
expuestos a las consecuencias del cambio
climático a nivel mundial aumento del
nivel del mar pero también hemos visto
las tormentas y los huracanes al final a
cabo nosotros vemos que hay
consecuencias brutales sobre la vida de
las personas y sigue habiendo muchos
desplazados internos dentro de honduras
es decir que la gente no se está yendo
porque solo haya un problema de
seguridad o de pobreza sino también por
consecuencias que hay que introducir en
la discusión sobre el tema de eeuu yo
creo que es un momento clave en la
historia de las relaciones es evidente
que eeuu siempre ha dominado la digamos
centroamérica en términos de política
exterior es evidente que honduras
siempre ha sido una ficha relevante en
centroamérica pero creo que bailén tiene
que pensar muy bien qué va a hacer por
varios asuntos primero el tema de la
corrupción porque cuando terminó la mcs
y una gran desesperanza y la nueva
propuesta que ha habido por parte de
biden no está a la altura de lo que se
esperaba por ejemplo involucrada a
sociedad civil evidentemente es
importante pero no es suficiente hay
elementos de por medio que tienen que
ver con la institucionalidad y segundo
punto yo creo que aquí también
relación con china si va a condicionar
efectivamente qué es lo que quiere eeuu
con honduras es evidente que no le gustó
mucho que el salvador cambiará ese
reconocimiento que taiwán hacia él hacia
china pero por ejemplo vemos que le
sirvió con el tema de las vacunas es
decir que aquí estamos ante un escenario
cambiante y está claro que por ejemplo
byd en digamos que tenía unas ideas
cuando llegó al gobierno pero ve que es
muy difícil ejecutarlas en la práctica y
el último punto que creo que es esencial
aquí es las relaciones de honduras con
sus vecinos aquí es indispensable que va
a pasar por ejemplo con guatemala o qué
va a pasar con el sábado porque
evidentemente hay cada vez más digamos
separación en las relaciones pero es
evidente que por ejemplo la popularidad
de bukele por ejemplo en honduras es
brutal y creo que eso muestra que hay
una un ímpetu en honduras y en
centroamérica por tener justamente
liderazgos más fuertes así sea que a
veces pues pongan en tela de juicio a
algunas algunos avances democráticos y
esto es esencial y es el último punto el
tema de la el avance del estado de
derecho creo que eso es un tema que
inclusive la unión europea ha trabajado
mucho pero la cooperación internacional
tiene muchas dificultades para
posicionar esos temas avances reales en
esos temas si me queda un poco de un
minuto para terminar el programa
conclusiones rápidamente jose el punto
clave que debe tener el presidente en el
momento en el que asuma la presidencia
de honduras que tiene que empezar a
trabajar un punto clave no se migración
economía asistencia por el cob y 19
usted me dirá
y yo creo que básicamente es economía y
kobe 19 el país necesita
generar empleo necesita ese grado
oportunidades para que podamos avanzar
si creo que eso es clave y si eso se
logra pueden avanzar en los otros temas
édgar rápido el perdón perdona en su
bloque de exclusión además de lo que
posee la educación la educación pública
en honduras ya venía muy mal y el cobre
-la activamente la destruyó un enorme
reto del paso gobierno es reconstruir la
educación pública en honduras y eso lo
va a tener que trabajar más nada -miguel
rápidamente 20 segundos totalmente de
acuerdo con el tema de la educación creo
que es clave dar formación profesional a
la juventud hondureña para que haya
salidas laborales es indispensable bueno
pues a mis tres invitados a josé a
edgardo ya miguel aquí en el estudio de
france 24 les agradezco por haber hecho
este análisis para nuestra audiencia en
el resto del continente en el resto de
la región de américa latina ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales de france 24 y
también a mi cuenta personal sigan con
nuestra programación muy buenas noches
[Música]